whistleblowers often risk their own
safety to right or wrong they feel they
witnessed a new CBS new series called
whistleblowers tells the stories of
heroic people who put everything on the
line to expose wrongdoing it is hosted
by attorney Alex Ferrer a former police
officer and judge in tonight's series
premiere he talks to people who blew the
whistle on a pediatric dental chain the
former employees believe unsafe
practices were used on young patients I
[Music]
lived in fear every day what I would
face yeah I was scared I think something
might happen you never know when money's
involved it's David versus Goliath it's
a huge corporation the intimidation is
there kool Smiles is a massive
nationwide corporation with more than
120 clinics catering to kids I was a
dentist and I saw unnecessary procedures
children being traumatized I was
stressed to my eyeballs they're taking
advantage of little kids
they were doing baby root canals on
teeth that could have had regular
fillings I would hear children crying at
work honey
meet dr. Michael Greenwald an online job
posting caught his eye
cool smiles typically targeted
recipients of Medicaid I thought it was
just wow this is a great idea we're
treating children they're underserved
we're gonna do some good unlike dr.
Greenwald who had 30 years of dentistry
under his belt cool smiles recruits were
mostly young inexperienced dentists
recent immigrants dr. Rai was one of
them was it dream job what did they
offer you as a starting salary the total
package was 180 thousand dollars but it
was a deal with the devil so what is
your first impression when you start
working at kool Smiles
production like a mill like a mill it's
chicken nuggets getting produced down a
conveyor belt
he says corporate owners dictated the
work to be done so each tooth went from
a 30 40 dollar filling to a 500 dollar
game it was money
it was production dr. Greenwald says
demands a cool smiles or dangerous the
faster you work the sloppier you can get
I maintain some records of names dates
procedures wanted to stop this it was
insane pick up someone concise the
stakes could not have been higher I am
dr. Michael Greenwald I'm dr. Rai I am a
whistle blower and I'm whistle blower
their biggest mistake was hiring me I
just got chills cool smile said in a
statement the company follows treatment
guidelines from the American Dental
Association an American Academy of
pediatric dentistry adding quote
treatment is provided only after
conducting a consultation and obtaining
the informed written consent of the
patient's parent or guardian Alex
Ferreira joins us now at the table okay
you've got us intrigued especially
following that 911 what is the state of
that child
sadly the child died a few days after
getting treatment at the dental
procedure performed at at kool Smiles I
do want to point out that the death of
the child was years after the
whistleblowers lawsuit was started but
the parents are in the process of suing
kool Smiles
and the doctors clearly were fearful
about coming forward what's happened
with those whistleblowers the all
whistleblowers go through a very long
and stressful journey and me they are
they they lose their jobs and most of
the time they are blackballed in the
industry and never work in the industry
again very often they lose friends it's
it's a really difficult process and
that's one of the reasons why we want to
showcase whistleblowers because they
really they really are heroes and they
do this because they know it's the right
thing to do these particular doctors are
still working our dentists are still
working as dentists but there is a
silver lining and that is that there's a
law that allows the government to reward
whistleblowers who come forward by
paying them a percentage
what the government recovers and that
could be substantial we have
whistleblowers who are paid millions and
millions of dollars for doing the right
thing they don't go into it for that
reason of course they go into it because
they want to do the right thing but it's
a nice surprise to find out the
government can reward you for that
yeah and heartbreaking though to hear
the the loss of a tragic absolutely
tragic
baby root canals thank you so much for
bringing this forward thank you and you
can watch the season premiere of
whistleblower tonight at 8:00 p.m. 7:00
central
right here on CBS